le président n'avait pas fait de
conférence de presse depuis 2019 hier
soir il s'est montré à la fois lucide
combatif énergique et puis dans le même
temps visionnaire puisqu'il a fixé à la
fois le cap et c'est le rôle du
président de la République et en même
temps il a donné des applications il a
il est rentré dans les détails à côté il
a fait à la fois les deux je trouve
qu'hier en parlant du réarmement de la
France sous toutes ses formes je crois
qu'il a été à la hauteur de l'enjeu
justement un des rements dont il as
parlé c'est le rement démographique avec
un con de naissance mieux rémunéré que
le congé parental et un plan aussi
contre l'infertilité les écologistes qui
dénoncent un discours paternaliste
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez écoutez moi
je trouve que le discours hier qui
appelle à la fin des fausses illusions
mais plutôt à l'effort à la création de
richesse alors et qui a de fixer un cap
pour le pays ce qu'on attend du chef de
l'État c'est un FA et le cap de natalité
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que la France qui
a toujours été en tête dans matière de
démographie aujourd'hui de démographie
aujourd'hui doit à vu sa courpe
s'inverser et que inciter les jeunes
couples avoir des enfants souvent plut
tôt plus jeunes et avoir plus d'enfants
en France c'est c'est réarmé aussi la
France dans ce domaine-là plusieurs
annonces concernent la jeunesse service
national universel qui pourrait être
généralisé en seconde l'apprentissage du
théâtre l'expérimentation de la tenue
unique dans une centaine
d'établissements le doublement de
l'enseignement civique c'est au niveau
des attentes des familles et aussi de
tout le corps enseignant je crois que ce
qu'a voulu dire le Président c'est qu'il
voulait faire des républicains et faire
des républicains c'est le rôle de la
famille c'est le rôle de l'école c'est
le rôle de l'entreprise c'est le rôle de
l'environnement général c'est le rôle de
la vie quotidienne je pense qu'il était
bon de de le rappeler non pas de façon
paternaliste comme je l'ai entendu pas
ici ou là mais de rappeler que
simplement dans son mode de vie dans son
respect vis-à-vis des autres on a besoin
aujourd'hui de redresser la barre parce
que ce n'est pas le cas mais il est pas
très moderne sur ces questions avec les
l'enseignement comme cela un peu à
l'ancienne qu'il semble pronner non je
crois qui moi qui Mo qui a connu cet
enseignement à l'ancienne moi qui a mis
une blouse quand j'étais quand j'étais
lycéen que j'étais jeune aujourd'hui je
pense que ça forme aussi les caractères
que ça apprend ça réduit les inégalités
de destin pour parti on peut les réduire
de cette façon-là et ça fait partie
justement de l'enjeu que va porter le
président pour la France
demain